je m'affale et un négociateur
je suis le lieutenant de police max
verne aventures un otage s'il ne cède
pas à nos revendications nous ne
pourrons pas leur donner ce qu'ils
veulent à ça je peux tout de suite vous
le dire nous comptons sur les
négociateurs pour nous sortir de là
sinon vos hommes devront prendre
d'assaut le bâtiment car il ya des
[ __ ]
tout le monde se demande si le
gouvernement choisira la négociation ou
la force l'armée dans l'immeuble d'à
côté ce serait des sms sierra mort ils
lancent l'assaut alors faut tout faire
pour bloquer en est on sait qu'une
partie des otages et au deuxième étage
on vous donne une journée c'est tout et
après on commence à les tuer un bar à un
temps d'assaut immédiat a déjà été mis
au point en avant je veux que le mec est
le coeur d'un lion et la caboche d'un
[ __ ] de juge
on sait que vaut mille têtes vont nous
attaquer on les entend ils font du bruit
je veux que nous trouvions une issue
pacifique ils vont tous nous les
abattons
coups de feu dans l'ambassade
préparez-vous dash et de parler de plus
longtemps que vous pourrez a sonné mais
vous voulez que je les aide à massacrer
ses seins je veux que vous sauviez les
otages
le premier ministre que le monde et les
britanniques puissent voir de quelle
façon notre gouvernement fait face au
terrorisme
ouais tous les deux nous pouvons arrêter
la violence
nous avons encore une chance à la peau à
la clau
[Musique]